it was a story but he made the round he
walked off the set and is he no longer
on the show anymore i don't think the
show's on anymore but i think that was
part of it
uh are y'all talking or yeah
i don't know [ __ ] yeah
you want to talk to me yes the show was
still on right uh in fact um
the show uh the goldbergs we're talking
about goldbergs is uh
still uh
very much on on television in fact it
got uh it was it had 18 episodes this
season and uh got picked up for a full
22. so
the show's doing quite well
jeff is no longer on the show
um
but
you know
some [ __ ] went down
he was in and he's he's talked about
this you know he was in vanity fair
talking about
his some of his um
i don't know he had he he had
spoken to
the hr department
several times for you know several years
about what was going on
and there were problems on set and
he didn't feel that way so
he didn't feel what way he didn't feel
that
uh he was what he was that what he was
doing was a problem
the
it was part of his apparently his
process did you witness some [ __ ] that
you were like
i uh
i
you know this is it's difficult to say
because
you know i'm
you know i'm i'm a hired gun i don't
i'm not a serious regular on the show
right i
they they got me to come in and and do
some comedy and then and then i leave
right so
their internal stuff is
is there but you witness some [ __ ] and
here's the good thing he's not on the
show anymore because he so he can't get
you fired
no he can't get me fired but
i i i you know it's it's a difficult
thing to do
talk about other people's [ __ ] the other
people's things you know right well
richard kind he's on the
richard kind
he's such the nicest guy in the world i
you know i i i love him
and i also love tuna fish if you guys
know richard kind looked him up look at
him bing-bong so he you know he always
has you know him and jeff were you know
they're pals they are powers they're
very good friends they're they're
compadres
and they come from second city
and
he uh
i don't know why i'm i don't know
yelling i mean but that's what but he
sounds exactly like that richard that's
right a hundred percent and i i don't i
think you know richard i think i'm i'm
only saying that so you don't ask me
anymore jeff garner question really
you don't want to talk about jeff
garland because i i what what can i say
you know you could say god he was the
biggest [ __ ] on set ever i i could
say that but you don't want to but i
don't want to say that because he wasn't
the biggest [ __ ] on on set you could
say he's one of the biggest [ __ ]
i've had on set you know i could say
that too
you're not i'm not i'm not going to say
that because the the thing is you know
like i like just knock you down with
that yeah
and this is why all right all right
george clooney
you